hey I'm glad to be here and as Michael
said that this will be a an
interdisciplinary talk maybe sort of
like a fusion cuisine of education and
psychology and computer science I want
to talk about Big Data and discovering
tacit implicit knowledge and using that
to improve learning and my overall
argument is here on this slide I want to
first try to convince you that we are
not aware of most of what we know and
learn and as a consequence the typical
approach for designing instruction
whether that's writing a textbook or
authoring lectures is fundamentally
flawed by a basic lack of information
that self-reflection that we use to
design in lectures and textbooks and so
forth is drawing on too little
information so instead we should be
basing instruction not just on our
intuition we shouldn't give that up but
also being informed by data and by the
science of learning and I'll illustrate
for you some approaches we've taken to
draw upon data to tap into what we what
what we as experts or what students
trying to acquire expertise know and
learn and as well as examples of using
computational modeling to dig into those
issues importantly we want to then
demonstrate that those insights really
work by redesigning courses based on
them and comparing them in experiments
to show you that you get improvement so
that's the closed loop part I'm going to
start with a little background then then
give some examples of these data driven
models and give you a brief sense of
this computational theory that we're
developing of student learning in these
areas so going back to some of the early
foundational work at this is sort of a
CMU take on early AI in cognitive
science history but it's one that's
relevant to to my core way of thinking
so Newell and Simon did this work on
human problem solving way back in the
early 70s and they
you use this technique called think
aloud where the head experts think aloud
as they solved problems and that was
their primary data source for tapping in
to the nature of expertise and you know
that work led to things that came later
I mean they built the first
chess-playing computer but you know of
course we see today how powerful those
technologies have evolved to be but they
also had insights on into the nature of
expertise including the notion that
experts acquire something like 10,000
chunks of knowledge to become an expert
that's probably already an indicator
that it's may be hard to reflect on what
one knows if the volume is is that high
but another thing that that was very
compelling about some of the work they
did for example in chess was this notion
of perceptual chunks and it is best
illustrated by this task of giving a
master chess player a board position in
the middle of the game say there's 28
pieces on the board 5 second exposure
sweep it away ask the player to
reproduce that board and they can do
that very accurately and quickly novices
can't do that and interestingly experts
with those same 28 pieces randomly
placed on the board can't do it either
so they've learned particular patterns
of pieces just like you learned patterns
of letters that form words and you can
quickly remember what those letters are
when they form words so 22 chess players
learn these patterns and it's not like
they're trying to do that they're trying
to play chess right but it turns out
that their brains acquire these patterns
and it might actually even be functional
but they don't realize that they're
doing it herb Simon and others did some
later work in developing not only models
of doing complex tasks but adaptive
systems that could acquire knowledge of
doing those tasks so this was early
symbolic machine learning adaptive
production systems was a key approach
she one of the really I think
interesting papers and this is sort of
little known proceedings of the national
academy of sciences paper that Simon was
involved with and this
well among other papers really made a
big emphasis on the hard part of
becoming an expert is learning that
essentially the retrieval cues or if
part of our knowledge we often can
articulate what we do in an expert area
those are the actions in the then part
but when and why we do them is is the
hardest part of learning and also
probably the most tacit of what we learn
they did some demonstrations actually of
using this to guide better instruction
in in math and physics there's also work
developing cognitive architectures like
akhtar and sore and and some of that led
to intelligent tutoring systems like an
early work on a programming tutor
teaching the list programming tutor had
an impressive demonstration of teaching
programming and about one-third the time
it takes to learn programming in a
typical situation so one of the key
ideas in akhtar helps to highlight this
tacit knowledge thing and it's not
simply a I guess in in philosophical
terms these distinctions between
declarative and procedural might tempt
you to think that's declarative is what
you can say in procedurals not but
akhtar cuts it a little bit differently
there are declarative elements like the
structure of the perceived world that
are not necessarily easy to verbalize
things like the first language grammar
you know your natural language that
grammar you don't learn that explicitly
you'd have trouble explaining for
instance why you use the in in some
places in a noun phrase and not in the
other you pick that up like the chessmen
master through experience and through
exposure these perceptual chunks are
really powerful in expanding experts
memory organizing their intuitive
reasoning allowing them in essence to
make leaps of inference by seeing the
world in bigger chunks on the procedural
side these cues help look for instance
surgeons make choices in surgery
academics plan proofs social designed
decisions get at the conditions in logic
behind decisions in planning if we ask
how much of our knowledge is each of
these there are some empirical
investigations that suggests these
things we can't articulate this tacit
knowledge is about seventy percent of
what we know the remaining thirty
percent that we can directly articulate
is actually quite small and I'll say a
little bit more about that but if you
want to ask me later you can probe a
little bit about how how those numbers
came about preface simulated student
Theory I'll get to later wanted to put
on the table a few of the claims that
we've that are part of that theory so
following this tradition the notion that
much of our learning comes from inducing
from experience from examples and by
doing and that that kind of learning is
mostly outside of our conscious
awareness that kind of a learning
involves challenges for our brains
corresponding to the things I was
emphasizing earlier learning cues for
decisions or the if part of the
production and learning the deep
representational structure of a domain
from perceptual input and the
computational modeling framework we have
have mechanisms to perform these two
challenges and part of this approaches
is to suggest that you know what we
actually spend a lot of our conscious
time in learning and instruction verbal
forms of instruction is somewhat
secondary in the process and and so I
think there's you know something
challenging there in the sense that it's
in our conscious awareness so it feels
more primary but in fact if you look
deeply into how learning works it it
guides us but doesn't really get us
there so visually here's the dilemma
experts if you believe this notion can
describe only thirty percent of what
they know
the rest we don't know what we know so
instruction based on intuitive design
lacks information and thus is likely to
be somewhat flawed so here's here's a
piece of that evidence from a study out
of that involved interviewing experts in
a surgery procedure catheter insertion
and this is recording four different
surgeons how many of the steps in the
final procedure that they came up with
through these multiple interviews and
probing and some rational extension of
what the procedures need to be how many
did they original what proportion that
they originally mentioned and this
thirty percent comes from essentially
that the decision steps are a minority
of what they're mentioning so how this
thing I'm illustrating here is a form of
cognitive task analysis there are a
number of ways to do it think alouds
that Newland Simon did are one of those
ways Clark and colleagues have done this
structured interview form one thing
that's really powerful about what
they've done from a education
perspective is they've taken the
insights and redesigned instruction and
then compared that instruction to
existing instruction so in this surgery
domain the control condition in these
studies was teaching that the surgeons
and med schools have developed before so
these really smart people right they're
developing a really high-quality course
but they're doing it largely based on
their intuition when they did these
think Aloud's they discovered subtleties
of the surgery procedure like even the
way in which the persons holding the
needle here that weren't being
articulated in the course in the
original course and when they modified
the course based on these kinds of
insights they got much better outcomes
and they they interestingly not only
track those outcomes through doing the
typical kind of post paper-based
post-test in which the surgeons who were
in the treatment condition did better
they also
that their performance in the field and
they were much better at the surgical
procedures as demonstrated for instance
they had many fewer extra insertions of
the needle um so very practical
important and powerful outcome there
been up another ton of these kinds of
studies you can imagine they're kind of
expensive to do both the this intensive
interviewing process as well as the
redesign in the experiment but about six
or so in a small medicine analysis
really showed a quite substantial effect
across these studies of this kind of
approach so one of the things I've been
interested in over the years is can we
find ways to build upon this extremely
informative approach but find methods
that get beyond some of the issues of
subjectivity and time costs that these
methods incur and take a more
quantitative approach that uses data and
does so by asking two key questions one
form of data is to look at the
difference in difficulty of related
tasks and by seeing those difficulties
we can infer through the difference what
cognitive processes might account for
those empirical different differences in
difficulty and the second is looking at
task performance over time to see
practice learning by doing and some
tasks may transfer to others but not to
another category and again we can use
that to make inferences about the
underlying valuable cognitive processes
the components that make our
intelligence plastic and changeable so
to give an example of that in a more
academic domain in early work that we
did developing an algebra course and an
intelligent tutor for algebra was
interested in what I was hearing you
know from working with teachers and I
guess to some extent it felt like my own
experience that story problems in
algebra were difficult so here's a this
kind of contrast between tasks or we
tightly controlled features of this task
as you may have observed these of all
the same mathematics all three of these
problems have the same answer the only
thing we're varying is the context of
the presentation this is an equation the
top as a story the Middle's in English
but without the story and question is
which is most difficult for students and
can we get a sense of what process
students are using to solve these
problems so what do you guys think I'll
show you data from it's about was about
an April in ninth grade algebra class in
Pittsburgh so they've had you know maybe
seven or so months of experience with
with algebra and high school algebra
class who thinks the story problem you
wanna you Gavin hypothesis I thought as
you say it seemed like equation would be
the hardest why that I think stories are
in natural structures that people
understand and vitamins the sympathize
with may be tagging so that they'll make
the first one easier what about the
second well the second one is closer to
two like at least like a story but still
it's not as emotional ends yeah well
there's no story there right yeah their
so you said it's high school
students right yes mmm then I guess it's
the equation is easier phone up and it's
the story story problem and then I think
the word problem is probably the most
difficult for them yeah tell me a story
Sorry Sorry hardest how many say word
i'm going to say equation come on stick
with it yeah i was actually designing
this thinking i could get some insight
into how story problems are solved
translated into equations this might be
a sort of intermediate form and i could
unpack that the you guys are mostly
consistent with what math educators
believe unfortunately most of us
we are wrong um what the data showed is
that you were right maybe not for the
right reason but um yeah the big
difference is actually between the
equation and the word problem so it's
not about the situation it's actually a
small effect of the situation on decimal
arithmetic operations we never see
students subtracting $66 from ninety
cents in the top problem but they do in
this problem sometimes subtract 66 from
the 90 so that's the that's essentially
accounts for the difference between 70
and 61 percent but the big difference is
between the problems expressed in
English and the one expressed in the
language of algebra yeah aren't you
really giving them instructions as to
what to do as you say if I multiply it
by six and then at 66 i get if you know
so to me that almost seems like an
instruction that's what you should be
doing yeah we've replicated this number
of times and one of the things we've
manipulated is whether the operators are
made explicit or whether they're
implicit and more natural way of saying
it they'd be implicit but that makes
almost no difference it's about seventy
percent correct when their implicit
there's some slight effects on
strategies in in that case but but no
big difference in difficulty yeah there
are lots of difficulty of the problem
also depend on the proficiency of an
individual students so amount we
replicated these kinds of problems with
CMU undergrads at one point and you'll
be not surprised to hear that the bars
shoot up like two ninety-eight percent
but that one only goes up to 94 so it
actually replicates with with you know
mean sats of like 06 90 or something
like that yeah but the other thing we
did is we manipulated the difficulty of
the problem so one feature of difficulty
that flip flops this relationship is if
the story or equation refer to the
unknown twice so X minus point 2 x
equals 38 or Ted bought a coat at a
twenty percent
discount he paid $38 how much was the
original price there the story problems
harder than the equation and it's
because there they need the equation to
solve it here they're actually able to
solve these problems without using the
equation but what's the most interesting
thing about this is why this is hard and
why we don't experience it as being hard
and what our analysis suggested is
basically it's kind of a linguistic
phenomena there's a language of algebra
that your brain and its ability to learn
language without language that's how you
learned your first language is still
soaking up the grammatical patterns and
so forth it needs to because you don't
naturally know how to read this you
don't know how to chunk the phrase
structure that you should do
multiplication before addition you can
be told that but that doesn't mean
you're going to in the moment do it with
the patterns of areas we saw and in fact
the tight contrast between these two
suggests that the real difference is
that it's essentially not being able to
read this reliably just like imagine you
were in your first year of a Greek class
right and after nine months you were
asked to say what this means versus say
what that means it be easier to do in
English than it would be in Greek yeah
you test this on students from different
countries we actually replicated this in
Russia because a colleague of mine was
saying they start using the algebraic
language in second grade problems like x
plus two equals five and in a matter of
fact it actually didn't flip flop but
they're roughly equivalent they can that
can they had seven years of experience
by ninth grade with the algebra language
so they're actually able to comprehend
it better yeah is this the exact format
of the equation that you see the subject
in this study it was we had others where
we used 6x and that actually doesn't
matter yes she had studies where we did
a line instead of an X in a box those
are slightly easier with the line being
slightly easier than the bus box if you
can believe that i never believed it
would be possible but somebody
hypothesized that it would be somehow
fill in the blank
is more natural and small effects but is
that what you're getting at the 6x yet
yeah it turns out we thought that might
be harder but it turns out some students
don't know what that asterix means so
there's a lexical issue here and 6x is
again a grammatical issue right that's a
a particular grammatical form that
juxtaposition means multiplication and
just because I tell you it once just
like I could tell you in Russia how to
conjugate a verb doesn't mean you can do
it right say is there a distinction
because we want more experienced math
educators say vs um well it's
interesting you ask that we did do
surveys of teachers and in one of those
surveys we had elementary middle school
and algebra teachers and that algebra
teachers were the worst at this
prediction task they were the ones who
like many of us including me want to say
yeah the equations are easy right
because they're easy for them so yeah we
started use this phrase expert blind
spot the more expert you become in
something the less reliable you are at
predicting how hard it might be for
somebody use especially if that
expertise is rather tacit Lee acquired
and you don't have much conscious
awareness of it so it was I getting at
the nature of your question this that's
really okay so so sometimes teachers are
you know like this somebody who's like
what people will think is a really great
teacher right because he's really did
more for me than other teachers that
I've had and I'm wondering if they're
getting it something different from what
you know judicial how that dynamic
relates the person yeah well I think it
depends on what you mean certainly
people's judgments of teaching can go to
like personality and yeah but I think
ultimately what to the extent that that
teacher is being perceived as effective
because they're able to select tasks
that make dis subtle distinctions that
let me see let me understand something
that wasn't obvious to me you know that
other professor
would have thought it was obvious tho
those that would be consistent with this
theory in other words if I'm sort of
more aware of distinctions that make the
if part different even though the then
parts the same you know you need to
learn it two different ways and I give
you both of those examples I'm probably
to be a better instructor than the one
who just gives you the one example and
expects you to be able to induce and
generalize to the other context yeah but
Bunny's what the teachers needed by
estimating is because in a flick of
experts and therefore block and how it
is to be at office which is a blind spot
theory but it could also be that they
use for teaching and maybe catching
makes them better symbolic manipulation
and so you know it's really maybe that
they've taught students which is why
yeah well there is the issue that they
may be reflecting on their own ability
and it's easier for them there's the
issue that maybe it was harder but they
forgot and then the other one which i
believe is they never realized that they
were learning it because most that
learning like first language learning
was happening tacitly and implicitly
yeah have a question about what do you
mean by the linguistic be na minha by
the equation because because i'll be
when i talk about our simulated student
and how we use grammar induction to
learn algebra they'll make the language
analogy more powerful so yeah spent more
time on that then maybe I planned but I
think it's worthwhile here's a
screenshot from the middle of the
algebra cognitive tutor that we
developed a lot of activities like this
some are more like practicing your
server your backhand are more isolated
this one's a bigger task like playing
the whole game of tennis so that and
these bigger tasks students are
analyzing some intended Lee authentic
problem situation like comparing two
different cell phone plans and they're
using multiple representations not just
equations they're not shown but that's
part of it tables and graphs and
developing a model of the problem
situation using that model to answer
questions and as they're filling in this
table or drawing the graph or so
solving equations the tutor is following
them along able to assess every step in
the process and if necessary give
feedback when errors are made like
you're the student forgot the fixed cost
of that of the current plan but also
students can when they're challenged
with hard questions and aren't able to
figure out how how to go about finding
out when the two plans intersect they
can go up here and click the hint button
and and get help so two forms of
instruction here feedback on errors or
next step hints to for what to do next
and if the student is able to figure out
from this higher level hint that can ask
for a next one and eventually it grounds
out in giving them an example not of the
whole solution but of the just the next
step and then it's back in the students
hands to learn by doing so instruction
comes only when needed not when I think
you need to hear it but when you
demonstrate that you you need
instruction could be you've made an
error and it it starts with verbal
instruction which actually the data
suggests maybe not all that valuable it
ends with an example of what you should
do and that actually seems like that's
probably the most power if you don't
know the best thing maybe to just
instead of being told to get to be given
an example and then you can induce from
that given a lighter chance to learn it
with respect to giving a later chance to
learn it if you're making errors we're
tracking what skills you're having
difficulty with and then assigning new
activities based on this skill profile
so that better students were can skip
past stuff fast students that need more
help get more help in the areas they
need it and the way that's made possible
the fundamental piece of intelligence in
this system is the cognitive model a
system that can solve the problems in
the domain in various ways that students
can is just an example of that in the
algebra two way in two different
strategies representatives if-then rules
here for dealing with a problem like
that one either these are correct and
here's a common error if you have a
model like this and the crucial thing is
to get these right this is a kind of a
made-up example but I give you examples
later of how getting this right can be
subtle but all the instruction that the
tutor can deliver is based on this model
it will give context-sensitive
instruction depending on the structure
of the model as I Illustrated earlier
and it's also going to update the model
of what the student knows there's a
Bayesian estimation scheme here
underlying it to select upcoming
activities and determine the pacing so
this those skill bars are based on for
each student there's an estimate of the
probability that they know each skill
and that can be then used to select what
kinds of learning by doing activities
would help them the most then lots of
large-scale field trials of this it's
also been very widely disseminated about
600,000 students per year are using
these courses about two days a week and
those numbers those are not just
starting numbers those are finishing
numbers you know those are students
getting through these courses that but
it's about almost 3,000 schools are
using it across the country field trials
have been going on since the earliest
quazy experiment we did is reflected in
the graph here in particular this
represents one of the results we often
saw is that if we design assessments to
get at some of our key goals like
authentic problem solving and being able
to use multiple representations to
represent functions will get huge
results we get smaller but statistically
reliable results son on standardized
test questions many studies in between
but one of the most recent is actually
the largest yet this was about a hundred
and forty or fifty schools where classes
in those schools were randomly assigned
either to use the cognitive tutor
algebra course by the way it's a full
course we developed the text teacher
professional development and and the
software were there either randomly
assigned to that or to use a their their
regular algebra course and the the
effects here are particularly strong in
the second year of implementation and
the somewhat oversimplified result of a
very complicated analysis is that
students in the cognitive tutor course
over the school year learned about twice
as much as students in the traditional
algebra course a very rigorous
large-scale field trial these these
field trials have certain kinds of
weirdnesses to it that if students are
assigned to the condition they're
treated as though they got it even if
they didn't we've seen in some of these
implementations some of the school's
intend to have students use this
curriculum but don't actually use it and
these policy level studies require that
you count those students as as haven't
used it certainly issue interesting
issues there about methodology but the
real point I wanted to make about these
as well these are some pretty good
results there's certainly a plenty of
room for improvement both in terms of
the practical outcomes but also
scientifically we made so many decisions
in building these courses driven by our
own intuitions having insufficient data
or insufficient science to guide those
decisions so we created this learn lab
center about nine years ago with
generous funds from the National Science
Foundation around the idea that we could
use these widely disseminated
technologies as a way to do research so
these include not just our math
cognitive tutors that are used in mostly
middle schools and high schools but a
number of online courses mostly at the
college level developed at CMU through
the online learning initiative that can
distill was directing who is now here at
Stanford also work in language learning
domains and in a number of data sets so
using educational games so the key idea
here is it's kind of like you know
Google izing education if you will by
having these technologies out in the
field we can embed studies in them we
can collect the raw data and we can
build our better Theory through the
technologies is kind of a deeper
instrumentation of what's what's
happening in the learning process so the
social part of this infrastructure was
facilitating researchers some of these
have laboratory psychologists we wanted
to get out into the real world help them
run studies in schools by organizing
that process for them and part of that
organization is technical and that we'd
help psychologists implement studies in
these technologies so we have through
this process and actually increasingly
just through people adding to our data
repository we now have I think it's the
world's largest open repository of
educational technology data about 500
datasets from a wide variety of domains
but we also ran many of these in vivo
experiments or they use the language of
industry these a be test where instead
of that study that I showed you you know
what we're many billion all kinds of
things right that course is different
not just because of the technology the
text is different the teacher
professional development is different in
these studies they're they're tighter
principal testing studies where we're
varying one thing they might last for
maybe a couple weeks or even a day
session with a pretest and posttest
between them and so done over 300 of
those this graph represents a subset of
the content areas that were focused on
in those studies so some language
learning things math and science things
and on the other axis here are the
things that were manipulated like the
treatment condition had an optimal
scheduling of practice algorithm and the
control condition didn't and we use this
experience to put together a framework
essentially making some dichotomies or
economies of different kinds of
knowledge different kinds of instruction
and different kinds of underlying
learning processes that are facilitated
by those different kinds of instructions
so the taxonomy makes very finer grained
distinct distinctions but at a sort of
higher level here between facts that are
like constant to constant mappings like
an English word to a Chinese word rules
or skills which are mostly tacit
mappings of variable situations into
dependent variable responses and then
articulated verbal knowledge of
principles increasing in complexity here
both complexity in the sense of you
could look at description length that
get longer to describe but also collect
complexity in the sense that if we look
at the time to execute the corresponding
operations the time gets longer and then
we also have this dimension of different
kinds of instructional manipulations
that may be associated with learning
processes to facilitate memory or to
facilitate induction or to facilitate
understanding and again these get
increasingly complex too as sort of
characterized both theoretically and
temporally these books by the way are
some sources for many studies that you
know various paradigms of research and
educational and cognitive psychology
explored a lot of these dimensions and
been published in a lot of these
resources but we are trying to put some
organs an organization to that what's in
this content of this table is some
examples of particular studies so here
for instance that shows three different
domains we manipulated adding worked
examples to our tutors and the outcome
was positive for the treatment here a
couple studies where we had students
explain their steps and in some cases in
contrast to getting explanations from
from an instructor or in contrast to not
having to explain interestingly in some
domains we saw no effect of this self
explanation manipulation and there's a
a temptation in this graph and and and
the theoretical reason to believe that
that maybe there's an association here
that the complexity of your knowledge
goals should be matched with the
complexity of the kind of instructional
intervention that you focus on and that
complex forms of instruction like having
a classroom dialogue may not be very
effective for learning Chinese
vocabulary for instance so and that one
that one's rather intuitive but it gets
more subtle in some of these cases where
prompting students to self explain why
they chose a particular English article
actually enhances learning but it takes
more time relative to not doing it
without getting any more positive gain
and the fundamental theoretical idea
here is it's because that most of that
activity is not enhancing memory it's
targeted at hanszen enhancing
understanding but memories the primary
learning process for acquiring
vocabulary so I could give a whole talk
about that upper corner and we have a
recent book chapter that talks about
that but I not only is how it has a lot
of our bit work been more in the middle
here but I think this is is really sort
of fundamental and it's somehow
underemphasized cognitive psychology
loves to do studies about memory and
because we're consciously aware of the
verbal stuff at the top that's what we
mostly think about when we think about
instruction you know how are
communicating to each other in lectures
and the middle part often gets left out
because it's happening tacit Lee so
that's where we've been doing most of
our exploration I think just to give a
kind of sense of a status of where we
are we learned as much in the center
about what we don't know has we learned
about what we do know and I think we
know a lot I would characterize it in
that in a metaphor with transportation
so like we have Model T cars now it's
much better than locking or or having a
horse-drawn carriage right
but what we could have in education is
jet airplanes what it will take to get
there is sort of analogous it's going to
take a lot of work it's going to take a
lot of advances in the science and
engineering you know not of jet engines
or how planes work but in in deeply
understanding how learning works and how
we can use technology to make it easier
and faster and better so the part of
that development of understanding goes
to thinking more deeply about what are
the best forms of instruction and and we
often get caught up in debates about
instruction as if there were just two
ways to teach you know you've probably
heard about the math Wars of the reading
wars like the reading wars are phonics
worth versus whole word you know there's
just two different ways to teach her
math is like back to the basics or
understanding they tend to have this
kind of give students more assistance
versus more challenge character to them
academics kind of make a lot of these
binary they make binary distinctions to
just a lot more of them huh here are
some examples and the bold italics is an
indication of where the literature seems
to lean on a lot of these issues
although and and some of them there's
there's work in both directions and some
of these you'd find people disagreeing
on the status of them and some of them
which are apparently different in the in
that there are different paradigms of
work and different people involved if
you examine them closely these two
things are essentially the same
dimension of manipulation but one
paradigm is coming out with a different
answer than the other and it turns out I
think this is one of the things that
inspired that knowledge instruction
dependency that most of these studies
are about facts in memorizing facts and
their practice is much more important
than study whereas most of these these
studies were about skills and they're
studying examples as much doing that
much more than we usually do say in a
map in science class you know we get
homework assignments where you get up
problems to solve might be ten problems
to solve what this literature says is
that you learn more if half of the
problems were solved for you and you
study those half half of those problems
and solve the other half that gives you
more information to induce the patterns
that you need to learn and of course we
always give examples but the problem is
instead of giving five examples in the
lecture usually only has one or two and
then some of the subtleties that you
need to learn aren't represented in
those examples so you have no
information on which to base them so
extending this idea out a little bit I
started to think about how many
different instructional options that
really are and the fact that these
binary distinctions r you know already
hide some of the subtlety in the sense
that you can take a distinction of like
master focused practice versus
distributed practice and and come up
with a number of intermediate solutions
like gradually widen the the time
between practice intervals and you can
combine these dimensions together so
here we can take the dimension of study
versus test and combine it with the
other and now we're not at two we're at
nine but that's only two of the
dimensions right there's should the
examples be concrete or abstract or some
mixture should the feedback the
immediate or delayed should I block
topics or interleave them should the
instructor be doing the explaining or
the student doing the explaining and you
can again combine these with with for
the most part there's some exceptions
but for the most part all these can be
combined with others and there are many
more such dimensions which we've
articulated in this paper and so how
many choices are there two hundred and
five trillion is the is the number we
came up with so that's the design space
of instruction it's huge so if we want
to get to the jet airplane of effective
instruction there's a lot of work to be
done it's not going to be purely
empirical we need some theory to help
prune the space and guidance there
and part of what we did in this paper
would suggest some recommendations for
forgetting they're both by leveraging
large-scale experimentation online but
also theoretically by building a better
sense for how these different forms of
instruction function to enhance
different kinds of learning so I want to
say give you some examples now sort of
of this data driven process I mentioned
and how we've been going about that we
have done a number of studies using data
to to do various things and one of those
is to do a predictive assessment by
using online interactions to predict
end-of-course tests for example state
tests this is data from the
Massachusetts eighth-grade math test and
in online interactions in a online
system called assistance we're able to
predict from those online interactions
very accurately how students will do on
the test and those prediction models not
only look at student performance but
they also look at how dynamically there
how much help they're needed and we get
metrics of essentially work ethic
embedded in these models that are
predictive above and beyond how well the
students doing as to how well they'll do
on these tests we've had other work
that's used the log data from these
system interactions to detect various
emotions or disengagement gaming the
system and this is a part of screen from
an intervention scooter the tutor who
gets increasingly looks a little
frustrated with you if you're looking
like you're not engaged in the system is
one indirect form of intervention
there's also this help seeking tutor
that was built getting at helping
students acquire learning skills and
again driven by data another thing we
done with the data is run competitions
we did the 2010 knowledge and discovery
data mining or Kate
d cup here we challenged folks to build
better models of how students learn and
it was real effort to try to engage the
machine learning research community
community in understanding educational
data it was structured similarly if
you're familiar with the netflix prize
instead of having movie watchers making
ratings movies we had students here
solving these are observations of their
performance on steps in these tutors
over time and the data here is not their
movie rating but one if they got it
right on the first try without any help
and zero otherwise either they got it
wrong I've asked for help and in the
competition there was a held out a
section of this data the end of every
unit in essence and the competitors had
to build models based on the data they
were given submitted to the website to
predict the held out data there were a
hundred and thirty participants a lot of
predictions and the accuracy greatly
improved there was a fifteen percent
reduction in error over the span of the
competition in essence actually there
were models that were even worse than
this but realistic attempts started
about there it's a it's actually a kind
of interesting question what we learned
here I think the these better predictive
models kind of have a sort of black box
character to them and and so that was
one of those sort of frustrating things
about this but one thing we definitely
learned is that there is there is some
signal in this data and there's some
things to be discovered one of the
things that makes this possible in a
rich way and I think is really important
to reflect upon as we're seeing more and
more online activities in which as you
know we're getting data on students
problem-solving is the difference
between what's mostly out there in
in MOOCs and Khan Academy these days
which is you get a question it may be
reasonably complex you might sit down
and do some work on paper and 10 or 15
minutes later you enter a solution
online maybe it's two minutes later but
here there's actually two different
parts that are entered in these
intelligent tutoring systems and other
kinds of Morse graphical user interface
more scaffolded environments here's an
intelligent tutoring fan Lane built for
physics they really try to unpack the
problem-solving process so it's not just
the answer but the work students do
towards the answer the so the green
stuff here's is elements of the force
body diagram that students are drawing
and getting hit in this case positive
feedback because the green indicating
that they got it right on their entering
definitions of variables up here and
here they'd be writing down multiple
equations that describe the situation
and accumulate towards a final answer of
here they've gotten that equation wrong
so essentially the same kind of problem
but instead of do two data points we
have 20 data points and so that means
much better sense of what students are
doing and learning but also
pedagogically more powerful so let me
illustrate how that works here's one of
the domains we did some analysis in
geometry we were particularly interested
in students ability to not just bring
formulas to bear to solve problems but
to do that in more novel situations
where they have to combine formulas to
to say find the what's left over when
you take that circle and cut it out of
the square there when we get data like
this every one of these steps is
recorded in the data set and we can look
at the error rate across students the
average error rate over time to produce
learning curves and so a learning curve
looks like this we're on the x axis we
have opportunities to practice a
particular skill and the error rate and
the trick here is to the insight is that
we can
use this kind of data to identify what
the skills are so if we think that
geometry is a kind of skill you acquire
and every time you practice a geometry
problem you get better at it we can
categorize that data that way and and we
can create a graph and say does that
look like learning is happening is the
error rate going down and this is one of
the visualizations that's in data shop
this is a case where the knowledge
component model is suggesting that
there's just one component that you're
acquiring yeah are the housing exercises
ordered this is temporally the students
experience to work through problems like
that what order did they do each step in
each problems versus like it's literally
just in order of like the opportunity
that they were supposed to yeah if we
take the same data and when we label it
more finely so we make a distinction
between what we think the skills are so
now that we have 12 categories we're
going to renumber that to say what's the
first opportunity you had for circle
area and what used to be two in that
graph might be the first opportunity to
use circle diameter right and then we
can regroup Andrea verage and when we do
that same data reorganize we now see a
decline in error rate so this is
empirical evidence that there are
components of knowledge that drive
learning up there we don't see any
evidence of transfer if we think the
components this one big geometry muscle
that's getting stronger here when we
look at these finer grained components
we do and what's particularly powerful
about this technique is that it
continues to apply these are this is a
hypothesis about what the skills are and
in the aggregate it does reasonably well
but we can look at each one of these
individual skills and ask it is the
curve going down so when we do that we
we see some curves
are sort of reasonable we also see some
things like like this one which suggests
that hey this is starting off pretty
easy staying pretty easy and we're
wasting students time that's a quick win
to improve the system by reducing that
more interestingly though we sometimes
see curves that look like that original
one where the error rates not going down
it's staying high and that could mean
that they're not learning but it could
mean like that first curve in which we
know they're learning right it just
wasn't showing up because we had the
model of knowledge wrong that that that
those labels are off so we can dig in we
can say well what that composed by
addition what was it labeling it was
labeling these steps in these problems
and if we look at the error rate it's
high up there it's pretty low for the
next two and its intermediate here and
and here you have to switch on your
cognitive psychology math ed head and
think hard about what's really going on
to try to do this to understand
substantively what what's happening
after doing that we concluded that
tentatively at least that the first step
there requires that I really engage in
planning to figure out how I'm going to
combine the two areas once I've got the
plan all i need to do with new input is
is repeat the arithmetic I just have to
do this subtraction in it in this
problem it's different because it's
actually scaffolding computing the the
needed intermediate sub goals so the
planning is in part being done by the
scaffolding in the system and that makes
it slightly easier so now we take that
data a skip past this next graph and we
here's the the 20 different steps across
the different problems that were labeled
with this and the range of error rates
weary label it so that we get three
different skills instead of the one
represented in blue and seeing the
average here doesn't do a great job
we've got three different skills it's
not perfect but it's much better fit to
the data
more precisely we can use a legit acree
gresham model this is a generalization
of item response theory to build
predictive models that you know we can
get quantitative tests of how well
changes in the model fit the data the
changes are reflected in changing this Q
matrix that map's each step to the
skills involved the middle components
representing difficulty the last
components representing learning and
transfer over time and that's what's
producing these the predictions shown in
in the green and blue lines here so in
data shop but you can re-enter these
models and as you do so you get updated
prediction fit statistics like AI c and
b IC in root mean squared error on
various kinds of cross-validation and
what we often find is that the
improvement the reduction in error isn't
necessarily that big but as a matter of
fact we didn't change these models very
much ten components went to 12 by
changing one out of these keeping the
other nine the same two to three here
and so most of these models are similar
so unlike the k DD cup we saw a large
difference but we didn't know what it
meant here we have a small difference
but it's very highly meaningful we
understand we can interpret it and we
can use it to make action yeah please
one question boo who's the special
assessment part is it a people who are
trained in cognitive psychology / method
or is it well i would say ideally we
want course developers to be learning
engineers who know some cognitive
psychology they may know the domain are
they may work with subject matter
experts to do to use this data to
redesign courses as much would be good
probably normal AIC and viz sauce yeah
did you know but now I'm thinking more
of the course developer right like a
Pearson or a Coursera or wasn't actually
not course there because they're the
platform developer but yeah actually
that's an interesting
because of the college level it's
usually the instructor and so we either
need to get cognitive psychologists
working with instructors or get more
instructors doing discipline based
education research and learning some
cognitive psychology so here's the
here's how we take an insight like this
and redesign a tutor we're going to add
new skills to this to this kilometer
that'll change the way the pacing goes
and and better isolate the the practice
that's needed will sequence differently
and and what was most powerful actually
in this study is we design new tasks
that got at this hidden planning skill
we hadn't well enough identified and
this isn't sophisticated intelligent
tutoring in this case this is the
psychology guiding us towards a multiple
choice question actually but one that
gets at the essential need here which is
to learn how to plan better so you're
just picking which of these is the best
plan to solve that problem and so we ran
one of these in vivo studies embedded in
a school pretest post-test looked at
time to mastery and the first big result
is that time to master is dramatically
reduced in the treatment condition at
the same time we actually increase the
time they spent on test steps where they
were actually engaged in this critical
planning skill the consequence at the
post-test was that when we look at items
involving that planning skill they do
significantly better despite spending
much less time on the individual area
steps they're not doing substantially
worse there although it there is some
suggestion that we may be over did it in
reducing this and there are some subtle
reasons for that that we're going to
follow up on so yeah I realized that I'm
running low on time here but we've been
pretty interactive along the way I did
want to do one more thing which is to
give you a sense for how we can so this
involved a heavy amount of cognitive
psychology expertise to do this
interpretation can we build a theory
that can produce some of these features
automatically and the strategies there
been to create actually skip over this
next section is about a search mechanism
that search through these spaces of
factors that people can can propose and
it actually involves a sort of minor
version of crowdsourcing but I wanted to
talk about is can these cognitive models
be automatically generated and it goes
back to this earlier slide here where we
have the sim student theory that's been
implemented in a computational model it
actually has four learning mechanisms
three of them are about learning
production rules the how is the Venn
part where to look and when to do our
part of the if part and the fourth
mechanism for learning representations
this is the grammar thing I referred to
before there's a app key application
here is the potential that we could
build cognitive models and intelligent
tutors essentially by teaching the
computer how to do the task and and then
we'd have the model and the tutor would
come from that so this representation
learning part is the the newest and most
novel part of the maybe the most
powerful part of it it goes back to this
chunking idea i mentioned earlier and
we've used probabilistic context-free
grammar induction to learn the structure
of domains by patterns of co-occurrence
a frequency to build these chunks so
it's an unsupervised learning mechanism
that just like the chess master who's
seeing lots of boards it's going to
learn chunks because certain patterns
frequently co-occur and you can
represent those patterns in in a grammar
hug we have actually a two dimensional
version of a grammar where if you apply
it we haven't tried it with chess but
there's some potential it would work
there as well so since student it works
by being tutored you build some kind of
graphical user interface for your domain
you can enter problems into that you say
this is the start state now try to solve
it and at first Simpson says I'm stuck I
don't know what to do show me what to do
so in the interface you
and straight what to do you give it a
little clue like labeling the skills
that repeat it gives it a better chance
to collect positive examples it does
it's whatever version of parsing it's
learned so far it learns a production
rule the next step it says I don't know
what to do show me it'll in for another
production rule we give it a little clue
with with labeling that and again the
when these labels repeat that's when we
collect together com+ examples so the
interesting thing is when you go to the
next problem what can sim student do so
it's inducing from examples here so it
may or may not get it right yeah so
notice what it does here this is a
slightly different problem it's a less
sophisticated grammar it doesn't know
about the minus going with the three so
it said divided by three and then the
author says no that's wrong that becomes
a negative example the production rule
will modify its if part to learn more so
we now show it what it should have done
and it'll adapt and go from there so
we've used this in four domains here and
we've compared the model that it came up
with with the model that was generated
by humans most of the time it produces
more distinctions than the human
modelers did and most of the time the
consequence is that the prediction is
more accurate in one of these domains it
missed some features that the human
modelers got right in the prediction was
and wasn't as good it turns out some of
those six are not represented here and
if you combine the two you get that more
than then then either before again you
can interpret this because you can look
at the rules right and so it was a
pretty interesting insight that came out
of this that I hadn't really fully
recognized before what you think is the
hardest of these four problems the last
one
third one why the third one we said
apparently why because it's just a sign
in meters I would understand dividing by
a negative number by a number but I
wouldn't necessarily sent / side there's
no number there right it's grammatically
different in a subtle way if you
actually write the grammar you have to
write a different grammatical structure
Sims student learns a different rule for
that one then for the other three yes
then the last one was my intended foil
actually there's a little bit of
subtlety here as if you call dividing by
for a reasonable if not ideal thing to
do that's actually what the tutors doing
so but yeah it's actually quite a big
difference and it's a consistent one and
that's one that the that this machine
system now discovered and we can verify
that it better predicts the data in the
way I was illustrating before yeah one
teaching our prize just one one side of
the equal sign X is so pardon is
wondering does it have notes me ever
written that um yeah I have bought that
but if it's there it's pretty small um
and it might be because this tutor
pretty deliberately presents problems on
both sides but yeah that is one of those
subtleties that might matter but that's
the cool thing about the data you know
you have a hypothesis that it matters
you may or may not be right yeah and it
turns out I it's actually an interesting
question if we train students where the
problems were X is always on the left it
would probably do poorly when it first
encountered those on the right so you
know part of it goes to the variety of
the experience so just another
illustration of tacit knowledge and we
could go in to each of these four
domains and give other examples like
this have subtle insights so it's not
just about algebra it's about all
domains have these subtle things that
get students stuck right and we don't
necessarily real
lies they're getting stuck because we
were not quite consciously aware of it
so yeah that's the bottom line message
you don't know what you know intuitive
design is not reliable we need
data-driven learner models to do better
and that better is both in terms of
improving the science but also improving
the practice of learning there's tons of
stuff we did we've done out the in
addition to the cognitive some of these
motivational things and self-regulatory
kinds of things actually building on
some a dance work as well with inventing
for future learning and some of these
things contrasting cases and so forth
but yeah there's a lot of potential here
we think big data in education can
really make a big difference and and you
know I'd invite you to look into some of
the opportunities we have actually had
can if you're interested in finding more
about our summer schools or our the data
shop repository actually have some
handouts about that but thank you very
much for your time and the conversation
you